the Boston Celtics are who we thought
they were they got to the moment and
they did not look like they were ready
for the moment all of a sudden all the
shots were short again all of a sudden
they looked like they couldn't play
basketball with their left hand again
all of a sudden they looked like exactly
who we thought they were so let's think
about this like if you think back
through the series in every game that
mattered and now when I say matter I
mean matter for them like where the
pressure was on them they were supposed
to win they actually lost and quite
frankly they won on like a garbage
buzzer beater at the last second give a
dirk white credit like he made the play
that's how the cookie crumbles sometimes
but like they almost they gave that game
away